with structure like broadband internet
and it let's ensure that every farmer
every register every grower every
producer can make a profit as they grow
what fees and clothes not just America
but with so much of the rest of the
world and those farmers like anyone else
wants to make sure we are meeting the
challenge of climate change before it is
too late
let's open up technologies and markets
to them they've been provided an
incentive for capturing the carbon that
we're currently emitting in the air I
want to make sure that your gender
Charisse your family does not prevent
you from an advancing in this economy so
let's do a few things let us pay women
equal to amendment in this room
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
we must also confront the legacy certain
communities will be criminalized and cut
down based on the color of their skin
confronting confronting the legacy and
the consequences of slavery and
segregation and the continuous
repression of Americans is the only way
we'll begin to repair the damaged and
keep ourselves from committing the same
in justices and if we believe that we
are a country of immigrants and asylum
seekers and refugees of our strengths of
our success and yes our security
then let us three every single dream
from the fear of deportation
let's bring millions more out of the
shadows to contribute to their maximum
potential to the success of this country
let's not only let's suddenly fold this
country's Asylum laws
let us let us rewrite every single one
of those families that are still
separated today and let's remember that
every single one of us including those
were just three or four blocks from here
detained under the International Bridge
behind
[Applause]
we will
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all for all of the members here El Paso
a community to this distinguish itself
in a service just country going back to
mostly no sir no
you
[Applause]
for 17 years and counting in Afghanistan
27 years and counting in Iraq let's
bring these wars to a close and service
members families
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
especially to those communities
low-income too often of color that had
borne the brunt of climate change so far
this country has shown that we can do it
when the Western world faces the
existential threat of Nazi Germany more
than 80 years ago this country markets
the political will of the Western
democracies not only to win that war for
the following 80 years to make this
world safe for democracy and the
millions in this country into the middle
class this is our opportunity right now
to do something for a far greater
existential threat to do war not just
for those here with us today but for the
people of the future our kids
generation that succeeds though we have
to once again reassert our role on the
world stage or to do this but we're
gonna do that we've got to strengthen
these historic friendships and alliances
so many of them forged any sacrifice the
services of the men and women who put
their lives on the line and lost their
lives to this country let's make sure
that sacrifice was not slaughtered let
us make sure that we strengthen those
alliances let's send these love affairs
with dictators and strongmen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
it is our choice but to do any of this
you've got to understand that our
country's success depends on the success
of this democracy it is a single
greatest mechanism that humankind has
ever devised to call forth the power the
potential and the genius of people
around their challenges and their
opportunities and so every single
citizen must be able to the votes and in
every boat must count
[Applause]
registration is only possible if we
vigorously pursue a true democracy every
child every man every woman in this
country must be able to see a future for
themselves in his country otherwise this
country will have no future as a
democracy that means this is
extraordinary
unprecedented concentration of wealth
and power and privilege must be broken
apart and opportunity must be shared
with all
seek animal Sigma garden Olympus
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you allow ourselves to be defined by our
fears or differences instead we shall be
known forever after by our ambitions our
aspirations to resolve the creativity
the service and the sacrifices we
brought to bear in order to achieve them
our ability to campaign in this way with
people not corporations or PACs but
people come together not only to ensure
that we win the nomination not only to
ensure that we defeat Donald Trump in
November of 10 to 20 people in every
state in every territory from every walk
of life coming together to show that the
power of people is what is necessary for
us to accomplish our priorities I am so
grateful to be able to run to serve you
as the next president of the United
States
I'm so grateful for every one of you who
has joined or will join this campaign
and sacrifice some part of your life for
the success of this great country
together together we can make sure that
America fulfills its promise for
ourselves for each other and for every
generation that succeeds us Thank You
apostle
thank you everyone god bless you and God
bless america
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]